welcome back sam take it away sam take
it away
[Music]
buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and his thousand-year-old winery one
time
the spanish inquisition came to his
place and asked
if he had to follow the line for the
catholic church
and he was like i don't appreciate the
catholic church and then they put him in
an iron maiden and that's how the bam
iron maiden was formed that's it right
there
that's it right there that's actually
the singer of iron maiden
is a great is a seventh great grandchild
of that man it's actually a scottish
folk
song john hernandez
sam can you uh can you play me something
really like heavy real quick
that's a swedish folk song
[Music]
yeah technically that's a swedish folk
song wow
i guess all your music sounds the same i
[Music]
guess
all right all right all right all right
all right all right
stop the presses that's enough
can you keep the guitar in hand for like
funny little accents when a good joke is
made
yeah no so so they can make it like a
bad night anymore
i know no laughing in this podcast no
laughing guys because today
we're talking about some pretty
laughable subjects at times
uh you know you just never know what's
going to happen next when
is the algorithm going to be be
perfected by all of humanity
only human nature is the algorithm man
see that okay yes
this is what we want to get into today
uh
you know humans created robots right and
as part of our creation of robots like
or or eventual creation of robots i
don't know if we have or have not yet at
this time it doesn't matter
the point is that in order to create a
robot you need you need algorithms you
need
you need algorithms within the software
within that robot
to make it function now we have all
kinds of different relative robots in
our lives we're using
zoom right now which is in it's in and
of itself a robot
whose job is to record
group video from you know you know
assumes job is so anyways
does humanity does humanity manifest
these these the the results of these
algorithms
or do they manifest themselves yeah
the question is like does an algorithm
manifest the humanity
or is it just it's just serving the
greater purpose and we would have
manifested things like that anyways
like right but real quick before we get
into that i want to give a shout out so
there was a
uh on the today i learned subreddit the
mary poppins thing that we had posted on
corridor crew
became like the fact of the day or what
was the only letter i got voted to the
top
and i saw them a bunch of comments like
hey you watch quarter crew everybody
wants to watch quarter crew and i saw
something like i knew this was coming
a week beforehand because i'm a true ton
and i'm like
heck yeah true thompson i'm giving you a
shout out to whoever that was that said
you're a troton in the subreddit
on the day i learned yeah that's host
that's nice yes yeah that's a good day
yeah so anyways it's a lot like
algorithm thing like
so i was on a one-wheel ride and i was
talking to dean actually
and you know we're talking about how
like you know
social media very much influences how we
talk to each other you know maybe if you
don't use it very much it doesn't
influence you but
you know there's a huge chunk of people
that do use it frequently and it
influences how they talk to each other
but even then it's becoming something
where it's like you know
when we consume media at this point all
the media companies are kind of
building ais to serve you more of what
you like or that's the idea you know but
it's not always that
it's not always as nice to you as you
want to be sometimes
it's more about getting you to stay on
the page longer or getting you to watch
more minutes so it's not about
giving you the best experience for your
entertainment it's about you know these
other things that they're
sometimes serving yeah but you know this
you know these algorithms for example
like you know the google's ad algorithm
influences the kind of articles that are
written the kind of articles that are
written then
you know that can influence and that
dictates the narrative of history that
you know of your modern history
all because of how the ad algorithm is
playing what plays for clicks and all
that kind of stuff
now to be fair this story is all this
time you know getting headlines
sensationless headlines like
grab your attention isn't wasn't
something that was invented two years
ago and you know right
you know the internet was the thing i
mean stuff's been around forever
but four years ago like four years ago
when i was in
four years ago
but you know you know this stuff
influences people not necessarily for
the better not always for the worse
either
um but it's definitely shaping things
and the question is
you know everybody says like oh the
algorithm is shaping people the
algorithm changes what people see etc
etc
but is it is the algorithm not just an
extension of human nature
like is it not just is the algorithm not
just
us humans having our own internal
algorithms which have existed for
thousands and thousands of years is it
not just that not being put into
computer form
like we we seek out things we seek out
confirmation bias we seek out things
that we want to
you know that back up what we've already
seen and believe and things like that
and like we don't need a computer to do
that it's something that's just
naturally a part of us
and the computers are just doing the
same thing
but you know like it's making more
efficient it's a robot it's a robot to
help
you just have you know indulge in your
human nature more
you know actually that's kind of funny
actually the latest curse gazot
video um is pretty pretty interesting
and i was watching it the other day
because it's basically talked about um
you know different classes of
civilizations or different types you
know where it's like you have primitive
you have like
earth you know or planet dominating ones
you have solar system dominating ones
you have galaxy yeah dominating ones
and then yeah you have those different
types of tiers
and then um i believe we're 0.4 right
now by the way
what in point for what our
star citizen level is point four
but anyway sorry i'm sorry um just
minor instruction there um uh what was i
gonna say uh
yeah solar levels of civil life yeah so
but basically it was boiling down to
like the qualities though that find that
kind of growth
though and it's you know it talks about
the idea of like
competitiveness uh a little bit of
greediness
um and like a little bit of oh shoot i
forgot what they boiled it down really
well into like these four like
driving traits of like a civilization
that grows
basically um but like it
it's you know like these algorithms kind
of embody that though
like that's what they are rooted at
their nature though you know they're
it's like he's like a little capitalist
so to speak so for lack of a better word
do you think that uh at major
uh like deep learning type environments
they have
uh i mean they must they must have
a meeting where everyone who's you know
working in these at the highest level
sits there and it's like okay what are
what are some of the attributes
the the the human attributes that we
want to use
to like term how this thing is
at the end of the day and they must use
words like okay it's a little bit
competitive
it's compassionate it's you know it it
wants to propel innovation um
it wants to be efficient at delivering
information
um because how else would you do it i
don't know how else you would do it
yeah let me let me boil down these the
qualities i found it's
curious competitive greedy for resources
and expansionist and i like i was
thinking about that like
you know on the onset you know there's a
lot of like bad connotations that are
associated with some of that you know
greedy for resources expansionist
competitive
you know like but at the same time you
know you look at a lot of these
algorithms
that are generated and like yeah they
might serve one purpose but ultimately
they kind of
fulfill all those yeah um because
they're all about like
you know the idea of like making the
most efficient
net possible that hooks people who are
in it
and also hooks and like brings them
closer in and then also hooks new people
yeah the thing that i've been wondering
is is whether or not that efficiency
at least at the pace at which it is
currently operating
is actually a good thing or not um
you know uh nico we were having a
conversation just
earlier today about twitter and we're
like we were like hey
um you know we were talking about the
merits of
of a record or digital twitter account
and whether or not it's something you
know we want to do x y or z with
but in that conversation we were talking
about
hey um you know it is this
is this a good platform right now um and
obviously
there's both of those are true is it
good is it bad
both of that's true right now it depends
on who you are
depends on who you are depends on what
you look at on twitter it depends on how
it affects you as an individual depends
what you do
but but obviously there is a we we
cannot
disavow we must recognize there's
a heightened efficiency when it comes to
your ability to find the like
information and to internalize it and to
spread it
whether or not it's actually real
information
um i think one of the most telling
things
it this didn't happen on twitter but it
happened on social media
i mean one of the most telling things
about
uh some big topical stuff that's been
going on
is sam you directed me to watch all gas
no breaks
i went on that channel and i watched a
couple of his videos
two in particular the minneapolis riots
and the pro the portland protests and
after watching both of those videos you
know
you can see in there there's a truth of
information
that is is is really only
succinctly presented in that video
it's like we all know there's people
that say this at those protests we all
know there's people that say that about
them we all know that we all know that
there's these
these like different types of people out
there who are responding to this
like social issue in different ways
but this video puts them all together
and it's like yeah here it is here
here's here it is in a bottle
you know like boom this is all you need
to know about this
and it's very like boom eye opening
and and so the efficiency of that is
like a miracle
of modern you know technology
but at the same time if he had some sort
of like
you know mission or what have you if he
had some sort of
sort of information that he wanted to
spread in a way that wasn't necessarily
just seeking truth seeking
he could very easily do that too you
know you very easily do that too
and you'd boom you'd consume it and
you'd be like oh that's
that's it and so in order to vet
like all this information you have you
have to you know you got to go to social
media you got to go to traditional media
you got to
try to read both sides you got to you
got to go through all this information
because you just can never rely on like
necessarily one of these algorithms
because
quite frankly you can't trust any one
particular one i mean we've all had the
experience of watching one youtube video
and then having our entire feed filled
with that stuff yeah
well it's funny because like you know
the conversation gets dominated like
back in the day
this is something i think you know kids
kids these days are gonna have to deal
with it
uh and you know i'm not the first person
to say this by any means but
back in the day we had a common cultural
touchstone usually when it came to the
media
you know there's like there's abc
there's cbs there's cronkite the most
trusted
man in america dateline nbc you know etc
um and so when when the media when like
you know when dateline
or any you know those like you know big
news network shows
had an important news story and they you
know shared it with you
uh you know millions of people saw it at
the same time it was broadcast at the
same time to all the houses etc
and it became a shared cultural thing
where it's like okay this is a big deal
for america right now because
millions of us saw the news broadcast
where they said it's a big deal
but now we don't have that anymore um
like i don't know who the number one
billboard
singer is because honestly i don't
consider billboard charts number one
anymore
like everybody's broken down into little
demographics
and you can be entirely within your
bubble and you can know of nothing
that is occurring without the outside of
that bubble and in a way
it is a good reminder of like hey step
out your door and look around you
and start with that start with what you
take in with your own eyeballs
if if the news is telling you that the
world is burning
and you look outside and everybody's
happy you go downtown and everybody's
happy
you drive around everybody's happy then
maybe the world's not burning you know
but at the same time the other thing
they kind of realized is like you know
it's kind of like we live in a
post-truth society thing is like
we also live in a world with like almost
eight billion people now
at any point in time anything is
happening at any point in time you can
find a cop being shitty
at any point in time you can find a cop
being good because they are both
happening simultaneously all the time
because when you
when you're rolling the dice eight
billion times every day
you're gonna find an example of anything
you are defined of course
and you no longer no longer have a
central authority saying this one is
important
this one isn't and everybody gets to
find what's important to them for better
or for worse
and it's kind of weird and you kind of
see you see this floundering that
happens kind of like as human beings or
like
we need that pinnacle like what what's
supposed to be important like for a beef
moment it was like the black lives
matter movement everybody's like racism
is bad we can all get behind that it's
like yeah we can get behind that racism
is bad and then it's like
cool but in practice what does that mean
do you change police funding do you
change the laws do you change
representation media
just becomes a big mess you know
obviously because everybody has a
different idea of how to address that
but you know it's like as human beings
like those are things that we still kind
of had that cultural touchstone where
most of us have had the upbringing where
it's like yeah racism is bad we all
agree upon that you know it's like
very few of us have had an upbringing
where we would think otherwise
right but like the fact that like we
have to go that far to find something
where everybody can agree upon it like
just shows you how
fractured everybody's become with the
internet being able to connect
people and the niche things they enjoy
to the niche
servers of those of that content that
those people enjoy
i mean this is a we're going pretty deep
here and it does bring up a deeper
question
um like the question of
of objective truth and even
even even less so the question of
uh like even just moral truth
and and um
whether or not you know i think so so
we're in an interesting point because i
recognize everything that you're saying
uh these these are all things that are
happening right now
but there's another side to this and
it's
it's easy to hear all the things you
just said and to like
and go oh you know what the hell you
know uh
what's going on and to sort of get a
sense of anxiety over it
but also humanity hasn't
changed you know yeah we have we have we
have
may have changed our ideas of of of
certain
x y and z but in terms of
the thing that i'm always reminding
myself and i've you know
i think you know we're all in our
mid-30s now
right like but by the time you get to
this age
one thing i didn't realize when i was
younger is like okay no
nobody in history no no other person no
other human being
in history has had any different
at a fundamental level any different of
a brain or body
than i have like if you if you were to
take all of it and put it all on a map
and you know it's not like it's not like
we look at like
you know other forms of of of relatively
intelligent creatures like dolphins
or uh you know high brained high brained
apes
and we say like okay that particular one
did everything for that species you know
we look at them and we're like
apes you know and then obviously we
identify within like
certain chimpanzee and bonobo like
groups they have hierarchies and
there's a lot of animals that have
hierarchies but like day to day
across a lifetime across 8 billion
lifetimes across all the lifetimes that
have ever been homo sapiens on the
planet
your brain and your body are literally
the same as everybody else's
so how do you accommodate for
like that which is telling you okay
there's there's
there's like ancient truths inherent
to humanity that have been passed down
through our biology
for longer than we have any concept
of of how long it's been and those
things manifest themselves within us
as desires as you know like yeah if i
stomp on your foot you'll get mad at me
yeah exactly i hate that 100 years ago
you're so eloquent jake you're very
eloquent there but
i'm kind of curious what your point was
actually so my point my point is
my point is like it's it's i was getting
to my point but my point is like
there's a shifting idea of like
well it's my truth there's always a
tendency right now especially i feel
like for people
for people to want to say well this is
my truth and
no one can take my truth away from me
which i understand but i
don't necessarily agree with because
yeah when you forget when
if we just sort of arrogantly
like shuffle off and set aside
all the history of our own evolution
that i'm talking about
then i think we're at risk of like
missing something
important about about ourselves and
about
how we take some of these problems like
how you
take information and present a
monocultural like
touchstone and move forward i
you know i i agree but you know i think
i think
it can be also summed up with the idea
though that you know
especially in a world right now where
there's um
where all perspectives on a certain
subject are amplified to
the maximum so to speak everything from
the large voices to tiny voices
i think the problem that that ends up
actually creating more than anything
else is a confusion
from an execution standpoint because i
think you can prove almost any fact
right now to be honest like like you
know if you make a bold statement
anything from like a scandal with a
president to
like a class of people who have felt a
certain injustice
i think you can prove points uh that
hold truth
that support both um or any any
any opinion kind of surrounding it how
is that okay how is that well i think
i think it's a matter of just you know
we're living in a world where because we
get all those perspectives we can find
truths in almost
like there's enough of these situations
and voices now
being contributed to all opinions that
you can find
truth in um at least some of these
voices
like certain people's experiences or
certain people's
you know actions or whatever so you know
yeah you know just to bring up two like
really simple examples
you know we recently saw all right
there's um
like anti-racism demonstrations black
lives matter
there's a big talk about police
brutality and what that means and
there's many cases that support the
truth that there are there are egregious
uses of police brutality and then
there's also statistical facts
that you know maybe you look big picture
and it seems to diminish those
opinions but they're both inherently
true that like maybe
it's a it's a problem here it's not a
problem on this scale or whatever but
the point is is that yeah
both voices are still technically
correct um yeah
you can tell me that police brutality
isn't a problem as much as you want but
if the cop
shot you're right the other day like i
don't care
because they're shot by the cops and
that's what i'm saying
and but anyways but what that leads to
though is i think there's this
issue that niko's talking about with the
idea of like all right what do you do
now and
and like so what can you do about that
and i think that's
that's that's the big issue right now
which is like you know you have these
situations where
an execution on a decision that affects
millions or if not billions of people
basically
you know that's that's where things get
much less
i guess i don't know forgiving in a way
or like
much less compassionate in a way you
know because like now you're starting to
deal with like all right well from a
statistical standpoint if i do a tweak
over here
what's the ripple effect through time um
even though it might solve
you know issue a in the present it
causes
issue b in the future and
i think i think that's the main thing
right now is that because of that
huge amount of voices it's more
difficult than ever to be able to
actually have a concrete
execution on a concept or an idea um
because i guess it's it's harder to sift
through
these truths to find that direction
yeah well let's let's let's let's go
with that for an exam
as an example for for just a minute and
see if this goes anywhere but
to take the to take the uh police
brutality against
african-americans example you have
right the actual
amount of brutality
being committed by white officers
against black individuals
in terms of how many deaths that is to
the black community
is like incredibly you know incredible
it's technically small when compared to
the general population right
but looking at it
as examples let's take our most
egregious examples
well those are also you're right those
those are
also true so
if you're if you're if you're
responsible for coming up with like
youtube's algorithmic approach to this
do you do you go for something in the
middle do you like
pair it with like opposite information
uh
do you like well it's like you kind of
have to in fact that's an issue i've
been finding here like
the other day i had to kind of like step
back and go like man what are these
youtube channels and podcasts that i'm
listening to it's like
they're all like really angry and i feel
like they're all starting to like
they say they're liberal but then they
talk and they lean really conservative
or like really libertarian on stuff and
it's like
you know it's like i do generally agree
with a lot of these statements but then
it starts to get to this point where
you're like
okay hold on like i i'm falling into
that echo chamber
yeah but like is is that just like the
state of
online like commentary when it comes to
like
these podcasts than youtube like or are
they are they
is that style of youtube channel like
i'm talking about like the
you know i mean joe rogan is i guess the
catch-all example because a lot of
people he features
are in that like left libertarian
area um there's there's a lot of
conservatives for sure on there but like
yeah i feel like i don't know everyone
complains about canceled culture and the
social justice warrior thing a lot and
the left-leaning stuff but like i
actually have been struggling to find
maybe maybe maybe it's just me but i'm
struggling to find like the solid
opposing viewpoints to a lot of this
stuff that i hear
um i can't i don't know i don't know if
that's
well yeah but well i mean maybe not
specifically that but you know it's what
what
like the softer version of that the more
reasonable yeah you know where it's like
these people are still wrong and
here's some more productive approaches
for this yeah
but like i just can't tell if that's the
algorithm
that's propping it up like internet wide
or if that's just because there's like a
lack of those
strong voices you know i don't know it's
gotta be a little bit of both at the end
of the day
like if you if you end up creating
something that's undefinable
to the algorithm it's not gonna get
shown people like
the only way that i'll get out there is
if people share it
but then again like people people only
share what they know
and they only share what they like so
how are you going to get
you know it's like medicine that they
taste bad how are you going to get that
to
people if they don't want to eat it you
know
let's talk about that like say you come
up with a
new approach to presenting information
or say that
you come up with a new strategy on some
form of like
social or political issues and the
algorithm
now you say it doesn't know where to put
it
it might not get views which is
certainly true
but how did it come up with those in the
first place
so so that so like it clearly came up
with
like okay here's what i do with this
information and here's what i do with
this information here
here's what i do with red cars here's
what i do with green cars
you know x y and z
off of off of some information that some
human being
was like putting into it but then you
deliver a blue motorcycle and it's like
oh yeah
what do i do with that i'm gonna show
that to you i'm not gonna show it to
anybody
yeah but what if so what if enough like
i guess it's like
enough people have to show it blue
motorcycles in order for it to get
enough information to like say oh blue
motorcycles is the category now
kinda yeah i mean it has to learn and it
can't you know just like
the thing that makes an ai different
than a person and you know this isn't
this isn't true for everything i'm
generalizing here but
it's kind of weird that i have to say
that all the time now it's always
disclaimer
i'm generalizing like yeah okay uh
anyways
the thing is like why don't we just wait
wait wait why don't we just call this
podcast
i'm generalizing well this is the new
name
yeah but uh ai
is good at taking something
and basing it off as something it
already knows what people are good at
and ai is not good at
is taking something that you've never
seen before hypothesizing what you might
want to do with it
and then trying it and you know
obviously you can kind of roughly
program that you know from a very vague
sense in a computer but like
you know i could show i could play a
song for sam
with a style and a vibe that he's never
heard before and he can listen to it
yeah it's good or nah it's not good like
people still know
they can feel those things you can use
your imagination to imagine what those
things would be like
we have to do it all the time when
writing movies and videos you know
because we don't always follow the
formula sometimes
we're trying something fresh so we have
to literally imagine from scratch
if this would be cool and visualize it
and try it
and a computer can't quite work that way
very easily because the computer
needs data to base a decision off of
where as human beings we actually don't
always need data
we can sometimes just go for it so do
you think
do you think that oh sorry were you no
no go ask a question
so do you think that is that that that
because that's obviously
i mean that's obvious i think what you
just said
so do you think that's grounds to say
well hey maybe there's room for like a
human
curator you know yeah well i think so
and that's kind of one of the things
that like i've been waiting to see take
off
is like a human site
before something whether it's like news
entertainment or something and
you kind of have that in places but i
think the reality is is that humans
like when you're curating it you're not
doing it to give people the best
indulgent you're not
like you could have a restaurant it's
your vegetables
yeah it's vegetables man yeah it's like
if you didn't curate it it should it'd
just all be chocolate
right you know if you didn't want to
curate things at a restaurant it just
all be chocolate but
right you know chocolate and potato
chips and french fries they'll kill you
eventually
yeah sometimes you get some really cool
things when somebody's curating it but
there's a reason why there's mcdonald's
in every corner so do you think that
yeah well that kind of actually that
kind of answers the question that i'm
about to ask actually uh
do you know do you think though that
like there's
there is no way that there could be an
economic model to support that type of
like
algorithmic but also human-based like
presentation of information not honestly
no but i think i think everybody's doing
their best and kind of splitting the
difference
at the end of the day like everybody
everybody hates on youtube but you know
it
but i gotta give them i can't give them
props like they're not
they could be so much worse they could
be so much worse and they're active
like they are so active and trying to
fix the problem maybe they don't always
fix it the right way maybe oh yeah i
mean
they definitely don't always fix it the
right way they definitely they
definitely have their own
like agenda of course viewpoint of the
universe and the way that the world
should be
but they they do you're right they are
active about it more so than
any other i can't like i can't name
another social media platform that is
more active about it and maybe that's
just because we're on youtube more
but youtube is the only one that's
actually truly active about trying to
not make the world a shitty place a lot
of people would argue they are but you
know what
cool great make that argument but at
least they're doing something
right and actually striving to make the
world a better place
is within the boundaries of you know
running a business and making boundaries
of how many ads they can sell yeah
right exactly yeah yeah
you know another another big thing i
noticed and this is like this is kind of
talking back to what sam was saying
he's trying to look for you know some
other things so
for example i'm trying to remember the
exact event something happened
it might have been the beirut explosion
or might have been something else but
there's some sort of event i just wanted
to go and find the sequence of events
you know like who who has done the
research just be like i'm not going to
spin uh you know i'm not gonna it's not
an opinion piece it's not a click bait
thing it's just uh
at 10 am this happened at 10 15 a.m this
happened
at 10 30 a.m just the facts right i just
want the facts ma'am
and i couldn't find anything because no
no that never gets clicks no one cares
about that stuff
everybody wants to spin on it so to
actually go and find the facts i could
come out with my own
conclusion on what happened was almost
impossible on either side
of the spectrum i don't think this is
the beirut explosion while i think back
on it
this is something else it might have
been
i can't remember exactly what it is it
almost doesn't really matter yeah it
doesn't matter
yeah because because that's i've had the
same experience
and i can't read it yeah it brings me
back to like you know
history class and you might remember
this term like primary source versus
secondary source
primary source is someone who was there
and wrote it down
and then you're reading their spin on
things now to be fair
you're still filtering it to a person
you're already you've already gone
through one telephone in your game of
telephone
but a secondary source is somebody
citing somebody
and these days everything is secondary
sources or you know arguably a tertiary
quad you know whatever it's like it goes
way down the line like and the funny
thing is like when you finally dig down
you can find a primary source
you often discover how much [ __ ]
people are weaving into it
because very often these primary sources
are very vague
and like that's it that's all the
information you get and like these these
narratives that people spin out from it
like it's it's all so much conjecture
and there's all this pressure to have a
story about everything
and to have an angle on every story you
know
yeah that's how human beings work you
know we need good guys and bad guys and
that's kind of the other thing that
i've realized is that we have a weird
perspective here at corridor
because we're in we're in kind of big
media
we don't really consider ourselves big
media but like at the same time i mean
we got millions of subscribers so we're
kind of big media you know
so we're in this we're like in between
where it's like we're still pretty
normal people we're not screwed up
by having like millions and millions of
eyeballs upon us at all
facets of our life um
but like when i when i think about when
i read about somebody in the news or
something like that
i see them as a person i you know i can
imagine them
not on set i can see like who they are
when they're not on camera you know
but i think for most people you know the
common man
they're characters they don't see them
as real people like
the real people are the people that
you're interacting with in your
day-to-day as you go to work and that
kind of stuff and
you know whoever whatever this big
celebrity is off in
los angeles that has this one scandal
interrupts like they're just a character
they're just another facet in the news
they're not a real person
and so like a lot of the way people
approach
talking about other people now on social
media they treat those other people as
if they're characters
i've noticed that a lot yeah the thing
is like i've definitely noticed that
where it's like
there's um usually when people do
something
that people don't like i i found like a
lot of the
ways that it gets portrayed as like look
how stupid of a decision
some of this person made or like like
let's pull things completely out of
context here like
like isn't this just like an
unquestionably dumb thing for someone to
do
you know like you word you word it like
that basically because that's your
headline
and like yeah maybe the articles kind of
supports that the problem is that it
very rarely kind of gets into the idea
that like because people are humans that
live and breathe and think like you know
a lot of people
even if we disagree with them some you
know like there's plenty of stupid
people don't get me wrong but like
sometimes when it comes to like
i don't want to get too too political in
this
this kind of stuff but um um
like i think the portland protests are a
really good example of this
because when when federal officers
i mean i just listened to the full
testimony of the department of homeland
homeland security's
like uh chad wolf whoever he is he's
he's one of the guys in charge
i just i listened to his full senate
testimony of like everyone foreign
good for you he was basically grilled by
this huge committee of senators and
stuff like that on what exactly
happened but you know when you first saw
all this stuff happening there it was
like all right oh my gosh it's the
gestapo
we're dealing with unmarked officers
it's crazy this is all trump's fault
what are they doing this is this is like
hitler stuff
and like you read the stuff you're like
oh geez this is like really nuts this is
bad like
why would why would you do that like why
would you
pretend to be the gestapo and have like
mysterious arrests and start like acting
like china
you know and it sounds really bad um in
your instant
that you instantly jump to wow people
are really stupid or mean or evil
or like they're like actively trying to
be bad
or something like that um because just
that's that's the that's the setup here
but you know you start listening to this
testimony and then he talks about it
he's like
hey uh you know like officers in
portland didn't do anything for 40 days
you know and they're like laying siege
to this building why was the building at
target
it's like we don't know i think they
hate trump but the point is is that like
in our like actual like our
our lawful binding document we are like
obligated to
stop this because there weren't
any other officers i mean like it wasn't
like a decision to go that do that it
was like a
like hey we've we've been trying to talk
to these guys in portland to stop it for
about 40 days
they didn't so unfortunately we had to
make we had to basically follow our
obligation to go and do this
everyone everyone had like
identification
or for like who they're working for the
reason they weren't wearing badges is
because they've already had multiple
officers doxxed basically
and that's why they didn't put actual
names on uniforms you know and you have
this full list of like all right here's
a step by step of
why all these decisions happened right
how we got here
and i'm not saying necessarily this is
good or this is bad
but what you're but what i can say is
that
it's not like decisions that are rooted
in necessarily like malice or
yeah you know which i feel like that's
kind of the emotional reaction
a lot of people spin on things we see
today and
like having whether you agree with
someone or not
you know when you read about someone
doing something it's it's like
if if if if headlines attribute it to
like ignorance stupidity or malice as
like the first thing it's like you
should kind of be instantly suspicious
of that
because you have to imagine what if you
were in that situation right and you
made a decision
and all right well are people going to
call you stupid or malicious
you know for for for it and like yeah
there's gonna be plenty of people who do
that
but ultimately yeah but you know these
are functional
thinking people behind both of these
decisions
um and i just feel like that that
that that barrier that you see is is is
often what makes people like lose sight
of
bigger picture elements here yeah the
biggest like the biggest distinguishing
factor i feel like that
between like real people versus like the
illustration of people that you get from
the news
is you know once it comes back to like
that movie character thing like when you
think of a movie character they're good
or they're bad
right you know or you can have
characters between but they are that
thing
the character is that type so in movies
that's how characters work
in real life you know once again i'm
generalizing this doesn't apply to 100
of everybody but
in real life everyone is good for 95 to
99
of the time and then they're evil from
one percent to five percent of the time
because that's how humans work we're not
at one point in time this is
my cardboard cutout it is me forever
things change with time and you know
every once in a while i make a shitty
decision because that's how people are
you cut somebody off when you're passing
or you're angry you give them the finger
you didn't get any sleep last night so
you snap at somebody
but then for all the rest of the time
you're good and you try to do good
things and maybe you help out with a
charity and you volunteered over here
because
in real life time progresses and you can
be doing a good thing at one moment
and a bad thing at another moment and
you can go back to doing good things
again
yeah people who just do shitty things
all the time yeah those are shitty
people and
you know they fall into that evil
category but the amount of people that
actually do that are very very very
small
the vast majority of people are good for
most of the time
and when you encounter that shitty
person they're shitty for that one
moment in time and you happen to be the
person that
had to deal with it you know exactly
yeah
yeah no um i did notice in that uh
all gastro breaks uh portland video um
so you know how everyone he was
interviewing he he typically blurs their
faces yeah well especially in
those ones because it's you know it's
people who could be
potentially identified and arrested and
and also i
i was hearing that they had a lot of
issues with uh release forms
in some previous videos yeah of course
um well yeah
people find out they look like idiots
online they're going to come after him
yeah
exactly that's apparently a huge issue
but the thing that i noticed was he
didn't do that for any of the cops
and you know there's maybe they are
they have masks of course of course most
of them yeah
but like the uh the implication i think
maybe i'm reading too far into this but
the implication is like
well you wouldn't dox a police officer
would you
[Music]
you know but people do and it's like
wait a minute so well it's also a thing
though when
we talk about the way police are filmed
in public
it is legal to film a police officer in
public
yeah with a without a release form right
um
and uh unlike like
as opposed to a person who can turn
around and
actually file a strong civil case
against you no i
no i hear you what a strange civil
rights thing or civil like liberties
thing to have to deal with from our
modern time like this is something that
only could have possibly existed really
until like the past couple years and
everybody's finally got phones in their
pocket
that are also uploading in real time
online where it's like we need to come
up with a blanket rights thing
and thankfully america you know
obviously there's cops that are still
shitty and say you can't film me
but thankfully like america as a culture
went the right way and said yeah you
should be able to film cops like that's
something that just that was just
invented now
like that's the thing that's going to
echo into the future forever i remember
i remember being in law school when that
was an issue
that was starting to come up and having
cases
come up and and that was the question
like whether or not
that that should be allowed and and yeah
we're setting a precedent that's going
to be a precedent for centuries
yeah hopefully hopefully yeah yeah
until everything's a holographic
representation the computers are the
place
i'll be honest though it's like at a
certain point it's like when do your
when does when do i get to have my
address encrypted
you know like i get to take the numbers
off my house
the post office has an encrypted like
tag which is not even an address
but like just it's it's a it's a data
point
and if you want my address i can send
you the encrypted file
and you can only access a data point um
basically if you if you if you click on
it to open it in google maps it alerts
me
and i have to give you permission to see
where that point is you choose you want
to use it
here's you know what i'm saying like
that's like in a weird way that's
actually
not a terrible idea
it's a good way to protect people that
are that have high-risk
jobs and things like that um you know
high levels of the government and stuff
like that but then obviously there comes
the
question of abuse on that it's it's a
whole thing
um man i just lost it i had another
whole other thing i wanted to add to
this
well i could steer back to the algorithm
if you guys want oh oh that was it that
was it um
okay do you think just just
hear this one out we don't know maybe
there's not an answer for this
but do you think that people would be a
little bit nicer to everyone else
and give a little bit more people the
benefit of the doubt if you just
uh just went around and just assumed
that that person
whoever you're interacting with lives
within
a quarter mile of you hmm
i don't know if that makes people feel
nicer i feel like that's the bristle
more like you know our
our territorial sides that come out okay
i think everybody would be nicer
next door to you like literally this
person that i share
property or share share building lines
or problems absolutely
i still don't think so because people
have neighbors they fight with all the
time i think everybody would be nicer to
each other
if everybody you were talking to that
you're having an argument with if you
assumed that the week before
their dog died like how much nicer would
everybody be
it's like somebody's kind of getting
pissed off and you're getting pissed off
and you're like you know what
last week the dog died i'm just gonna
chill it out a little bit
it's a family dog okay
it comes to the whole game theory like
tit for tat kind of thing
you know where it's like you you go
tit for tat when problems arise but then
you also have a nice random selection
pool where
each time you get a tit rather than
responding with a tat
you know it's it's the i guess the
forgiveness
element you know it's the it's the
empathy
element or empathy response that you
give to
offset that cycle yeah
what if everyone had
everyone was not a convicted violent
felon
and also had a f a concealed firearm
with a
permit to use it do you think then
people would be nicer to
each other oh yeah i mean everybody like
you've seen the the things i was like
yeah the protest when they brought
rifles they didn't get
no only at appropriate population only
at appropriate population densities what
does that mean
what does that mean it means you need a
low population density for
something like that to work if it's a
high population density it's
um you're too many innocent people are
going to die if
actual problem breaks out that's i think
it's certainly fair to a certain point
it's that roll the dice thing like once
again there's eight billion people
i'm i'm sorry i was gonna shoot all the
people again
anything's happening anywhere you pull
out a gun
how what what what identifies you as the
good guy
do you have a blue siren that you also
always wear you know
you turn on on your head that once you
start shooting your your lawful gun
that's something i've been thinking
about
can i hard tangent here real quick we
can bring it back real quick there's a
question for you guys
yeah all right it's late night it's 3am
you're sleeping door gets kicked in uh
you hear
a guy downstairs you grab your pistol
and you go downstairs and you see this
guy he's got a shotgun
he turns and actually
um and you run back upstairs and he
stays downstairs so some reason you
don't you don't shoot him
or maybe take a couple shots maybe he
missed maybe he didn't but he's still
downstairs he's shooting at you you're
upstairs and now you're sitting there
upstairs
you know at the top of the stairwell
waiting waiting for him to come up and
you hear him downstairs and he's waiting
for you to come down
okay yeah hold your phone and you call
them flashbangs
there's a guy in my house with a gun all
right
cops show up what keeps you
from getting shot nothing hold on
hold on hold on it keeps what keeps the
cops from kicking in
the door and seeing you with your pistol
and be like there's the guy with the gun
like how do you get through that moment
let's say you even shoot the guy right
let's say you shoot again
you describe the specific gun he's
holding make and model
you say yeah he has a black 1911 i have
the chrome 1911.
you do whatever you do that's what you
do you know you actually
that's how you do it you cerakote your
firearms the wildest colors
and you tell the cops very specifically
it's like i'm the guy with the green
tiger stripe m4 sam sam sam
with the gold side all right listen it's
unmistakable do not shoot that one
listen first of all what you're talking
about is entirely situational
and in any situation where there's a
firearm involved and
you are actively shooting at another
person and somebody else
shows up that's an authority of any kind
you you you immediately
you immediately at the first possible
moment you immediately identify yourself
as a non-threat
you put your hands up you put your gun
down and you say
i am not a threat that's all you have to
say
no one's no one's gonna shoot you if you
if you're like this
in the air and you're saying i'm not a
threat well that's what i want to hope
but based on the stats we've been saying
and that's that's all you are doing okay
and that's
i'm just saying it has happened i'm just
saying the true answer to this is you
better
freaking shoot that guy talk about the
high density thing
for a second as well that that i can't i
don't think you can just
write off the entire concept and just
say well it's a high density area so how
do you identify any good people so
therefore nobody can have
can carry a firearm i think that's
exactly the same like
logic that california has applied to
today
i think sam was saying you can't carry a
firearm i think it's saying just like
it's demonstrating with like you know
having having like 10 000 people on the
street and they're all carrying guns
might be a little
you know it's a little bit about i'm
talking about i'm no i'm jake i'm being
dead serious like
you know i'm a firearm owner and all but
like you know even in my neighborhood
like i'm not going to whip out an ar to
like defend myself because those bullets
are going to fly through a wall
no yeah that would be going through
another house because exactly the
density is high enough
yeah yeah yeah but once again but like
that's one element which is
density you know that's the topic
yeah each missed shot has a incredibly
high likelihood of hitting
the wrong person right right so that
that's that's one element
but then it comes from the
identification standpoint all right
it's like you say hey there's a guy in
this crowd with a gun or hey
there's a guy and and then now you pull
out a gun
and now it's like well now there's two
guys in the crowd with a gun right
which one's there everyone if everyone
has one how is it any different than if
nobody has one
i think the question is like how do you
get out of that without like it's kind
of like my question too or
or hey i'm the only guy in a crowd with
a bunch of people without a gun
and i'm a bad guy now what well yeah i
mean these are like these are the basic
like
you know i'm just saying i think the
density is i think that's
not trying to give you talking points
like this legitimate question
like it's a legitimate question i guess
i'm just wondering
how do you if you're ever in a situation
where you've had to use your gun in
self-defense
and you call the cops what how do you
get from the point when they're driving
towards your house to
when they're in your house and you're
cool and they're not shooting you
how do you get through that little
in-between there like this
hey i'm a here's a silhouette of a human
being don't shoot me
hey i'm the homeowner i'm not a threat
i'm the person when you say that when do
you say that
soon as soon as as soon as they're
you're able as soon as they're with an
ear shot as soon as they identify them
open up police
as soon as they come in like at any
at any point where by doing this your
own life is not in jeopardy
man that'd be scary it's not it's not
like don't shoot
me like and hoping they hear you and
like
you know the other guy can shout that
too right but we're but we're human
beings
yeah like how how else do you
there isn't a perfect solution there
isn't a clean solution to anything
the clean solution the clean solution is
breach and clear all right
all right so if you're trapped in your
house you you basically have to
formulate a plan you either have to use
a wall charge on your
wall charge on your own floor on the
second story so you can drop
down to the first story surprising from
behind
where you use the classic you you blow
you throw
you go all right all right
you blow or you can kick it down you can
use a door charge but you can kick your
door down
flashbang out into the hallway yeah
which is throw and then you go
like the old throw and go well just
saying you missing the first step jake
blow blow throw but sometimes blow can
be replaced with just a swift kick
through the door
yeah blow being like blow it up with the
charge
blow it down like you know big big bad
wolf like three little pigs yeah i'm
just saying
and in my case what that would mean i
unlock my door i slowly open it
i throw an airsoft uh popper grenade out
into the hole
and then i run out with my katana
did i want to use like a 20 22 like like
hollow point
it's not going to go through a wall you
got to be close enough to hit somebody
you know you want like two grenades
generally one for yourself
yeah if you get shot and you're going
out you can murder yourself just like
talking
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can murder
yourself
if they get you
[Laughter]
well we started off on algorithms and we
solved the second amendment so
yeah we did we did just remember
remember kids it's
you blow you throw you go that's how you
feel home invaders
this applies to both sides by the way
whether you're invading or outvating
yeah
it's the same yeah we want to thank our
sponsor uh due process
for this episode here new process is
almost available on steam
yeah oh and uh actually this episode is
coming out on
later in this week and it's going to be
the baseball line it's going to be live
on the store so uh
yeah so actually uh sorry new processors
new friends
our own store yeah um
we got a whole line of baseball merch
it's it's anime inspired and japanese
inspired it's really really cool
jay and i worked on it for jay from our
merch people
we worked on it from february to now and
we've perfected everything and you're
going to see it it's incredible so go on
over to
digital.store and of course if you're a
site member check in your
account management feature and you'll
get that 15 off promo code
yeah that's awesome speaking of merch do
you know if that boat
ever did we ever find the boat that has
our hats on it
the boat oh it's our mo cap baseball
hats yeah uh no so
wait wait clarify there's a boat
it's a ship it's a ship there's a cargo
ship right
no they'll call it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah sorry i thought it was like
somebody like painted our logo on a boat
no no no
new era hats on a dinghy on a dingy boat
no but we can use the dinghy to get them
using the blow throw go
tactic
you just have to scale the side of the
cargo ship find the container
execute yep
um yeah i actually i don't know i got to
follow up on that maybe
uh maybe they're going to ship now
yeah i like the fact that i have this
one-of-a-kind hat
that's like my hair not for long not for
long buddy
not for long this is also probably a
great time to remind anybody listening
that if you are a member of the site you
get 15
off of all merch and if you end up
putting in
i think the average order on the site i
don't know basically if you end up
putting in like two orders over the
course of the year
membership basically pays for itself
just throwing it out there for those of
you guys who want to save some money by
spending money
there you go it's like a credit card
that you pay off every month
right yeah actually that's kind of cool
it's kind of sweet yeah yeah
hey that's pretty cool digital dot store
whoa
out loud well uh i'd actually love to
hear
uh your guys's experience with the
algorithm uh so
if you can leave a comment i actually
any interesting stories about how your
like youtube or your instagram home page
have changed over time
yeah that would be really interesting to
see like
especially if there's like photo
examples uh but
that that'd be a fun thing to explore at
some point as well
i agree i'd love to read people's
stories in that because it's always so
like interesting seeing other people's
experiences and like their thoughts on
how it works
right and then imagine being that person
and going okay that that's what
that's what my feed used to look like
then it looked like that and it looked
like that
just never forget there's a point in
time on youtube where you can just copy
everybody's tags and title
and as long as you're a girl with
cleavage done
your pie girls there's a brief one in
time and made a bunch of money
by a brief moment like a year and a half
and we're talking enough money to retire
on yeah there was a brief moment
where yeah anyway if you ever wonder how
much money google has
all right guys well thanks for hopping
on uh it's a lot of fun
and uh let's do it again uh nico you're
gonna be gone next week but uh come on
have fun camping thank you and excited
to go
out into the middle of the wilderness
the uh
i've been going on a trip every year
since i was 13 years old up into the
boundary waters
and if you tally it up so that was uh
this is to this year will be like our
22nd year i missed last year
tell you that i was 22 weeks in the
woods that's almost a half a year of my
life
spent in remote wilderness like true
remote slowness
no cell phone reception no electricity
it's the most beautiful part of the
country in my opinion not gonna lie like
i've been the mountains
i've been you know to colorado been up
to washington
but dude boundary waters it's the best
it's like a special spot
it's it's it's like even the mountains
get like dry
you know yeah like and and like yeah
washington all that temperate rainforest
is cool because it's all nice and moist
but it's also really cold
almost all the time you know in
minnesota there that's like that perfect
balance where it's like
get all your nice moisture a lot of
lakes a lot of clean water great
swimming a lot of great green
um but then yeah it's like it's not too
cold either
you know yeah it's not florida either
i mean florida's fun but you know swamp
it's not yeah you don't have to watch
out for gators or snakes yeah
yeah but then you don't get to say
there's gators around yeah i mean
there's a little bit of like i'm like i
was a gator in the swamp
like it would be kind of cool to be able
to see that legitimately
maybe but then you'd actually be saying
that legitimately and then you'd be like
oh yeah that's true
you're so used to it you know it's like
oh there's a gator in the swamp it's
like ugh
again i hope he doesn't have a
he doesn't have a shotgun
yeah cool all right well everybody
listen to this podcast thank you so much
for checking it out really appreciate it
and
looking forward to chatting with you
guys in the next one
yeah yeah all right jake sam
good way to end the day i'll see you
guys tomorrow see you later
all right bye everybody bye see you guys